John and I are dating we're having a  good time and you know it's fun that was  Christie Brinkley in November opening up  to et about her romance with musician  John Mellencamp the pair recently  announced their split and tabloids had a  field day making claims about their  relationship that the supermodel says  just aren't true I feel like you know my  private life has been thrown in your  face enough right and I I just would  like to try to keep my private life  private the stunning 62 year old took to  Instagram on Thursday to set the record  straight  explaining quote as to the problem John  and I faced  it's just mileage pure and simple not  that exciting or salacious sorry  Christie also clapped back at  accusations that the pair broke up over  political differences the blonde beauty  defended her former beau noting that he  gave Hillary Clinton his song our  country for her campaign and added they  both plan to vote for her